networking for shy screenwriters
boy it's um it's not easy
for a rider
to break out of their shell
but i think that you can easily do it
once you start thinking about
what the end result might be
and when you realize that there are
other people who are doing the same
thing that you are doing
it becomes easier and being in a
writer's group is one way another is to
do volunteer or to be an intern
there are several it's just like you
know i'm at screenwriter i've been on
screenwriters
world i've done story expo great
american pitchers and these are all
wonderful opportunities to do volunteer
work and you get to meet other speakers
other writers you get to talk with some
of the people who are listening to the
pitches who belong to production
companies and agencies it's a wonderful
way to network to build your community
of colleagues
and that's another way really of of
helping yourself to become more aware of
who you are and your work and that at
the same time you're learning something
in the process because a lot of the
volunteers i noticed were sitting in on
some of the sessions and listening to
what we had to say and it was good to
see them there and know that they were
really you know they were busily writing
down information and they were what was
great is when i would see them sharing
it with other volunteers too
you